So when you're talking to your students about Jesus, do you automatically assume
that they believe Jesus to be God?
For years I did. I just assumed it until I got into a conversation
with them about it. And I realized that that's not always the case.
Not that long ago, I was actually talking with a couple of young guys that came to
my door. They were Mormons. Super nice, very friendly, had a great conversation with
them. And naturally, I went right to talking about Jesus.
Because at first we agreed on a ton of things, which I expected to be the case.
But then once we started talking about Jesus, although it seemed like we were going
to agree, it was very quickly realized that right where I thought we would disagree
is exactly where I thought we would disagree.
And I went right to John chapter 8.
And what I love about this passage is that Jesus just sort of flat out says it.
He just says who he is, which is partially why or almost entirely why they want the
Pharisees and the religious leaders want to kill him.
Because Jesus says before Abraham was born, I am.
And I asked these guys, what do you think Jesus means here?
What do you think this is? And they said, well, they stumbled from it.
They really couldn't come up with a good answer.
And they flipped to another passage and started talking about something different.
And I tried to redirect them back and it reminded me of a lot of the conversations
that I've had with students over the years.
And I, you know, making that mistake of just assuming that when we talk about Jesus
we're talking about the same thing.
So it's very possible that even in your context when you talk about Jesus you may be
talking on a different plane than some of your students are.
But this is a great opportunity to be crystal clear on exactly who it is that
Jesus actually is. Who does he say he is, right?
And that's why we have students focus right in on John chapter 8 because it's here
that Jesus makes the flat-out statement, before Abraham was born, I am.
The focus here is who Jesus claims to be.
So we ask students in the intro activity to put down who they think they are,
what their family and friends would say about them, and does that match up?
And do they have evidence for this?
Like, they think they're somebody.
They think they're a soccer player or a Christian or a musician or a football player
or whatever.
Do they have evidence for it? I used to call myself a football player because I
played football, but a person once brought it up to me and said, you don't really
play football. I said, well, what do you mean?
He said, well, you sit the bench.
So was I really a football player?
Probably not so much, right? So who do they think they are and what evidence for
it. So the trick of it is, is that if Jesus says who he is, but we have
evidence for who he says he is, now we've got something, right?
If someone says they're a basketball player and they scored 35 points the night
before, they're clearly a basketball player.
There's evidence for it. So this is the time you could actually have your students
do some of this interaction nicely and gently and with respect, of course, with
each other in your large group time to kind of get this idea of do I have evidence
for who I think I am? And do I have evidence for who somebody else thinks that they
are? So it'd be a good opportunity to do some of that interaction.
So in your small group time, one thing that I bet is probably going to come out and
you'll want to make sure your small group leaders are ready to deal with it is it's
not hard, I don't think, to look at Jesus as a
great moral teacher. As someone who has this wonderful religious sage
kind of vibe going on where they can read what he says about love and forgiveness
and acceptance and mercy and justice and all these great things that Jesus talks
about like in the Sermon on the Mount kind of stuff and leave it there.
And then go on and say, I'm going to try to follow what Jesus says as a good
moral teacher, but I'm not ready to accept him as the God of the
universe, the creator of all. Because if I accept him as the God of the universe and
the creator of all, that has wider implications for me than I'm ready to accept.
See, it's easy to accept him as a good moral teacher because I can choose to ignore
his teachings if I so choose to.
I can do whatever I want when I want, and when I choose to follow his teachings, I
look awesome. If I don't, no one's really going to notice, right?
But if I'm held accountable to the God of the universe, that's a whole other story.
So believe it or not, one thing that I found amongst some of my students back when I
was teaching was that a lot of students really loved Jesus
and really liked what he taught, but had very little
to no intention of ever following him as God.
And that bothered me. And it was right there.
It was under my nose and half the time I don't even know if I even noticed it.
But after a while it became very apparent when I started looking for it.
So it's changed the way I taught and it changed the way I started to converse with
some of my students and I started to challenge them.
I think small group in this time, in this lesson might be a perfect opportunity for
you to challenge your students in this question of how do you see Jesus?
Similar to how Jesus addressed Peter in Matthew chapter 16.
Who do you say I am? Ask your students, who do you say Jesus is?
And when they answer you, whatever their answer is, ask them why.
Get some answers out of them as to why they think that.
And if they're in that place where Jesus is just a good moral teacher, ask them what
it would take to get them to see him as God.
Is there enough evidence? I mean, you've presented the evidence.
There's a whole bunch of it. If you look through all the verses, We've only given
you a spattering of the verses that show that Jesus is God.
So what does that mean for them?
Is there not enough evidence, or are they just not willing?
It can be an eye-opening experience.
I'll be honest. I'm not telling you if there's anything you can actually do about it
physically right at this moment,
but it definitely will change the way you approach those students, the way you
address them, the way you teach them, and the way you pray for them.
So I would encourage you to dive into that.
It's sort of a scary place to dive into a little bit, but I would encourage you to
do that.